this video is sponsored by extra they're
a company that specializes in making
smart wallets and i was lucky enough to
receive one of them a few weeks ago and
i have been using it as my actual wallet
ever since
like the reason why it isn't completely
straight anymore is because i use this
thing
but i won't just tell you it's great i
will tell you why i love it
looking at the wallet you might think
wow that's really tiny
you can see i have my single dollar bill
but even looking at it right now all you
can see is
one two three pockets ladies and
gentlemen
i present to you i don't know about you
but this is the coolest freaking thing
so not only is it nice and compact and
really thin actually but like i said
before this
is a smart wallet so what do i mean by
that well in the first place it has rfid
protection
meaning everything in this 100 real
leather wallet is completely
secure but the reason why it's a smart
wallet is because
this right here is the little card that
makes all the magic happen when your
tracker card is in your wallet let's say
you lose it by navigating to the
application that runs the smart tracker
not only can you pinpoint on a map
screen where your wallet is
but you can also
my wallet is ringing your wallet rings
so that you can find it anywhere that it
might have been
lost it will notify you automatically if
you're out of range and several other
really cool smart features but here's
where it goes from cool
to insane so let's say all you have your
tracker card and you don't have your
phone what do you do
well my friends just double click
and voila my phone is now ringing the
wallet can track your phone
the phone can track your wallet the
smart chip is also solar powered so once
every three months just stick it in your
car's dash or something and you'll be
good to go
if you're interested in picking up one
of these sweet 100
leather wallets be sure to use my link
in the description below so they know
who sent you and now
on to the video oh minecraft
it's always so much fun to hop into a
new randomized world and set off in an
adventure unlike any you've had before
cutting down trees cooking up some food
oh yeah and mining
i mean with so many possibilities for
what to do and how to do it in the game
what even is this game really about
exactly
everything i just said about minecraft
could also be said about the latest
zelda game breath of the wild which has
famously been the first zelda game to
break out of zelda's established
conventions
and those aren't even my words those are
straight from aonuma himself
but this isn't news to anybody the
game's been out now for over
four years and it's obvious that even
though it didn't introduce anything new
to gaming as a whole
it's very different from the previous
zelda games and successful because of it
however have you ever asked yourself why
it's so different
in the first place and what nintendo has
learned from all of its success but
let's focus on that first question for
now
over four years ago when this game was
about to come out all of the gaming news
sources and all of the gaming youtubers
were focused on
one thing zelda plus skyrim
they all said that breath of the wild
was going to be like zelda and skyrim's
baby
because of one little aonuma quote which
literally said that he had played skyrim
before to be honest with you now that
the game has been out for
over 4 years now and we've been playing
through it and traversing every single
part of it and mulling over
every aspect of it the only real thing
that breath of the wild could have
gotten from skyrim is
weapons kind of since you've been able
to get other weapons in previous zelda
games before and if you think about it
you also can't credit the huge open
world to skyrim
because zelda was known for pushing the
limits of open world boundaries
decades ago hyrule field from ocarina of
time as many fans will remember
used to be the biggest game world ever
and everybody lost their minds when they
first played it so to me i feel like
going above and beyond in terms of map's
size was just inevitable if
zelda was going to keep progressing as
the years went by on the other hand many
people say that breath of the wild got
its open worldedness from skyrim
but again zelda has been known for its
open world since literally the first
game
if any video game has an in-game world
that is large enough to be freely
explored
and exploring it unlocks additional
optional content
that is literally the definition of open
world
gameplay not new to the zelda series by
a long shot so really in my opinion like
i said
the only thing that breath of the wild
could have really gotten from skyrim
is the randomized weapon drops possibly
armor as well but the armor drops in
breath of the wild are all just preset
locations so
that one really doesn't count and it
feels more like just an extreme version
of the kinds of different armor that you
could get in previous zelda games anyway
but i know what you're thinking breath
of the wild brought
so much more to zelda than just weapons
and armor there's the
non-linear story and the lack of
hand-holding that the game does the
collection of raw materials
climbing and cooking and that's all true
but my point is that none of this is new
to gaming which
means that it must have been influenced
from somewhere
the only question is what did influence
breath of the wild the most if it really
wasn't skyrim well here's a quote from
hidemaru fujibayashi
you know the director of breath of the
wild he actually just states very
clearly that
minecraft was directly an inspiration
for breath of the wild i'm not even
theorizing about that it's right there
and the more you think about it the more
you realize
just how much inspiration breath of the
wild took from minecraft
specifically the verticality of breath
of the wild's map design
minecraft invented verticality with its
randomized
three-dimensional worlds but these small
features aside
the biggest and most impactful influence
that breath of the wild took
from minecraft is at its core it is the
fact that breath of the wild's gameplay
is non-linear and refuses to hold your
hand as a gamer in minecraft you spawn
in and
that's it do whatever you want if you do
it wrong you'll probably get killed by
something and you'll learn your lesson
when you spawn in again
in breath of the wild you exit the
shrine and
do whatever you want i mean yeah most
players will go towards the old man
because the camera's like
there's an old man over there you should
talk to him and he does serve as kind of
a guide that points you in your first
steps but you absolutely do not have to
talk to him you can go left right
up down and you'll probably end up
killing yourself or being killed by
something and then
same thing you'll learn your lesson the
next time you spawn in and that's just
the great plateau which is the most
linear part of breath of the wild since
you do actually have to complete
that portion of the game in order to
actually experience
hyrule but after that this non-linear
style of gameplay really takes off
you can go free the divine beasts you
can not free them you can go visit
shrines you can
not visit them no matter what you do or
do not decide to do the game is very
clear that there is only one
actual point to finishing the game it
tells you right off the bat
two words defeat ganon after you defeat
him
boom credits roll you finished the game
that was the only thing you really had
to do
in minecraft there's only one real goal
defeat the ender dragon
after you defeat the enderdragon boom
credits roll and while yes
technically there is gameplay to be had
after you defeat the ender dragon
this is what most people consider to be
the end of the game minecraft the only
real thing that you need to do prior to
completing the game
similarly to breath of the wild's great
plateau is you need to create a nether
portal as this is the only way to unlock
the rest of the map
you could explore your world above or
the world below and visit other villages
and craft diamond armor or you could not
the choice is completely yours
how you get to the end of the game does
not matter and
this spawned so much curiosity and
exploration that was unique to every
single person playing and it's also what
i believe
most influenced the core of breath of
the wild and to be honest with you
why wouldn't it let me throw a couple of
numbers at you to illustrate just how
impactful minecraft is to gaming as a
whole but also specifically to the
legend of zelda in the past 35 years do
you know how many copies of the legend
of zelda have been sold as of this past
december december 2020 and
not including spin-offs like hyrule
warriors the zelda series has a very
impressive 114
million copies sold with breath of the
wild alone contributing to 23.14
million or over 20 percent of that total
number
minecraft which has just now been out
for 10 years by the way has sold
over 200 million copies
but it gets worse let's rewind to before
breath of the wild's release since we
are talking about the impact that
minecraft had on breath of the wild
back to 2016 i'm going to give the zelda
franchise an overestimation and
only subtract the breath of the wild
sales that happened march 2017. so as of
june 2016
zelda had sold 114 minus 23 from breath
of the wild so
just about 91 million units by june 2016
while the single game of minecraft
officially passed 100 million units
sold one single game outsold a franchise
that was 25
years old just let that sink in for a
second that is the only time in history
that that has ever happened
ever and it's not slowing down either if
you've ever visited the youtube trending
tab
it looks something like this minecraft
minecraft minecraft
minecraft minecraft minecraft minecraft
minecraft minecraft there are so many
more minecraft videos on this trending
tab
but quite honestly i got tired of saying
the word and now i need a glass of water
remember that early on in the video i
asked two questions one
why breath of the wild was so different
and two what nintendo
learned from it we've already spent some
time going over why breath of the wild
was so clearly inspired by minecraft
specifically now let's talk about the
future what has nintendo learned from
breath of the wild's monumental success
over its previous games
well here's another quote from the ceo
of nintendo himself mr shintaro furukawa
they see every year as a do-or-die
situation
which means that they continually have
to get better and evolve the kinds of
games that they make or
they consider it to be a total failure
death and we actually saw this happen
right before our eyes even though we
didn't really realize what it meant
at the time do you remember the first
breath of the wild teaser trailer way
back when when everybody was saying that
that
writer wasn't link or that link was
actually a girl or that the master sword
wasn't present in the game
ah those were good times but recall the
end of the teaser the game was initially
supposed to release
in 2015 then it got delayed to holiday
2015. then early 2016 then holiday 2016
and then finally they straight up lied
to us and told us that it was not going
to release
in march of 2017 but then it ended up
being released with it anyway you know
what i think
they were being inspired their do or die
mentality
saw minecraft that at the time was just
soaring above its competition and
blowing past all these other
complete game franchises and thought hey
we need to do whatever's working so well
over there or we will die
eventually and what if this is exactly
what's happening with
metroid prime 4 which has been sitting
in development for i forget how long
what if it's being changed around from
the ground up to be more like breath of
the wild
more like minecraft and don't think that
the cyber fiction genre can't be touched
by this sort of change for my fellow
halo fans out there remember those halo
infinite gameplay trailers
all of a sudden the map shows a lot of
verticality and you can navigate it with
a grappling hook and there's an
overworld map
that's never been a thing and what about
mario the recent game bowser's fury
shows
several signs of its core being changed
even though mario moves like he does
in 3d world you don't choose where you
want to go from a map you literally just
drop into the game world and
you're playing the game there's no world
selection or anything just playing the
game in whatever order you choose to
with a clear goal in the distance boom
everybody loved it because it was
minimalistic and it worked nintendo is
learning
so much from all of this to quote aunuma
they collect data to see what worked and
what didn't and here's another quote
from the ceo once again
they see the game market as more
volatile than ever meaning they have to
try harder for people to choose to buy
their games as opposed to others
competition is more fierce than ever and
they do not take the current situation
lightly and they are constantly looking
for new ideas
they put some core minecraft isms in
breath of the wild and boom
best-selling zelda game of all time and
game of the year 2017.
guys the first fruits of the future of
our favorite franchises from
video game developers like nintendo is
happening right in front of our eyes
whether we like it or not and i really
do believe it comes down to the greatest
selling game of all time
minecraft now whether you got something
from this video or this was all just
regurgitating information that you
already knew
i am genuinely very interested in what
you think about the influence from the
current
minecraft era of video gaming so please
let me know what you think down in the
comments below also thank you so much
for watching if you would be so kind
please leave a like on the video if you
watched all the way until this point the
almighty youtube algorithm hasn't been
being very nice to gaming creators these
days you know the ones that don't
solely cover minecraft so every single
like on a video helps push
channels just like mine back into
youtube's favor and if you did just like
the video
thank you so much also be sure to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already to stick around for much
more content to come i'm gonna be
uploading a whole lot come e3 this
summer so you're probably gonna want to
stick around for that also also real
quick before i end the video please give
a huge welcome to juan
v who has recently joined the ranks of
my bandit crew
if you're interested in helping the next
video come to life and helping old
bandit here
buy food for himself click on that join
button located below
or the patreon link in my description or
do like a one time thing and pick up
some of my merch
some pretty cool stuff down there check
it out anyways guys it's been real
that's all i've got in this one
this is massintenderbandit signing out
and hoping you have a wonderful rest of
your day
[Music]
you